everyone welcome to my talk about a
student-led Corps beyond the
introduction and I hope that is what
you're here to attend because that is
what I will be talking about the goal is
to cover some of the things that we
normally maybe not see at conferences
about a trip and courses what can be
your introductory talk and hopefully or
I can pretty much guarantee that I think
everyone will leave this talk with at
least having seen something they haven't
seen before before I get started I just
wanna my name is Chris Clun I work as a
software developer at a company called
active solution in Stockholm Sweden and
I spend most of my time doing software
development web web scenarios mostly and
cloud and I was to do a bunch of public
speaking so I enjoyed going around and
telling people the things that I've
learned along the way and then picking
up what everyone else has learned as
well so we can share the knowledge way
I've also been an MVP for the last nine
years County I think it is and it's
given me sort of an an interesting view
into a stuff that core and the things
you can do in there which is and what
I'm trying to bring with this one here
as well but you're not here to listen
about me so I'm gonna show them oh so
it's basically just that was all the way
through there are there's only one more
slide attempt but let's just go and jump
straight into visual studio so I'm going
to show a couple of different demos here
and I'm going to start off by having
this initial application and I should be
about that but here is called awesome
sauce company
and awesome sauce company has some em
place and when you go in to look at
these employees you can you can see what
they've done and who they are and you
get this URL up here that says local
those slash users slash - and for one
we've got theirs that's your regular a
strip net routing you get users slash
and then the IB or whatever you want to
be which is kind of not the greatest
experience and it's not very good for
search engines so I would like this to
be more of a search engine based process
which like slash pendulum or
there are ways to do that you can get
there are NuGet packages that will do it
but actually not that hard to build
something like that on your own so let's
look at let's start a file for this
application as you can see it's just a
pure base phonetic or application with
controllers could use and what we can do
in it from the core which most of you
potentially already know is that you can
jump straight into configure here and
you can actually attach to the incoming
and outgoing requests so I can go and
say that that you can see here I have a
I need one more thing that's right I
need to pull in a little reefer your
cool users every posit Ori for users and
in the request here so whenever a
request comes in to the web server it
goes through all of these middlewares
and I just added my own mid we're here
so if it's not a static file that's
being used the request is going to come
into my callback here and I'm just gonna
check to see if there's actually a path
if somebody did go to just slash then I
don't want to touch it but if there is
something after the slash I want to go
ahead and actually look at the URL
that's being passed I stay in or the
path that we passed in and then I look
at the path and I verified that it's
more than just slash and then based on
the path that I'm getting in I cut off
the first slash I just get the path
without the first slash and then I asked
my users repository can you please get
me a user with the name based on the
path that's being asked in but here's
the cool thing this is the really
important part that I want to highlight
and that's the fact that I can rewrite
my request so coming in I can easily
write a middleware that goes into HP
context did you request object and just
rewrites the path so most of the
property is on request the request
objects and and so on or get set so I
can rewrite this so whenever a
middleweight when you can see in the
request comes to my middleware when it
passes out and I called the next part
here I might have rewritten it but
nobody actually really knows that I
rewrote the path because once it gets to
the routing part and it gets to the
endpoints part and it ends up in two
controllers they are just going to see
that old your
which is gonna be users /id I go back
out here to this thing here my old
address still works that works fine but
I can also go and say maybe Lamar like
that and Americans why it does not work
ah sorry wrong button let's restart that
pain and then go to slash hedy lamarr
and apparently this is starting out
really well not good start out end up
thing here let's try this why am i older
sudden not getting any requests coming
through at all that's interesting
because I'm not getting anything at all
it's a story right sorry about that guys
I'm working on it that comes in here my
pathway is slashed as fine she thought
that I should go to flash and be they
said because I'm spelling it wrong Lamar
the head of Lamar whenever I go to head
a little more I get a and it should
refused a psych history boo sorry give
me one last right here and then I'm
gonna give up I think I know it is there
it is
I'm the parity spelling it wrong sorry
so that now ends up weird if I look at
here it comes in looks my path which is
gonna be hella mark it takes to Hedy
Lamarr part replaces the dash with a
space and then it asked for a user with
that name that replaces it so if I could
in a breakpoint here we have a look at
my call here do slash anyone without us
do slash handy - Lamar when I come in
here the request path is gonna be Hedy
Lamarr I go through left on I go through
all these steps you can see it and just
go ahead and rewrite it the request pass
it's not
you search like one and whenever I call
next is going to be bad and it's gonna
work
hey yeah besides me screwing up early
this is pretty cool it's a very nice way
to hack into very low level interface or
API I always dreaded or and actually
modify requests both coming in and going
out but I'm not a huge fan of putting in
middle works like this we really should
be putting in our middleware it's in a
nicer way so but those who you haven't
looked at building your own custom
middlewares it's actually not that hard
you're just gonna pull up a middleware
solder and I'm gonna add a new class in
here and I'm gonna call it name rough
thing in middleware there like that so a
middleware is basically something looks
like this so it's a class it doesn't
have to it doesn't have to implement an
interface it doesn't inherit from a base
class all it really needs it needs any
constructor that takes a request
delegates and it needs a method called
invoke a sage that returns tasks and
takes an HTTP context pretty much
everything you need or a middleware what
I'm going to do is I'm going to move my
code implicit little where and have it
reusable so I'm going to start off by
I'm gonna pool in my users repository
like that and I have an issue with
needing to be like that and then down
here I can go ahead and I can basically
just go and say name so this code here
if you have a look at this code is
pretty much identical to the code I'm
just had in my startup I just moved its
wrong being in line in my startup which
if you have a lot of mid where's your
startup file becomes this big unwieldy
thing but having you in a separate class
it's reusable I can put it in a last
library I can put it in two different
projects I'm working on and with the
proper configuration it's gonna be quite
reusable and I cannot go here and I can
change my app reviews to have good news
middleware like that and name writing
middleware that
and that's gonna work exactly the same
it looks a little bit better
and this as I said cool because we have
God reusability so I can move this
middleware between different projects
I'm not too happy about the registration
here because we're all used to
registering middlewares like that right
so you don't use something so I want
this to be outdoor use name routing
instead of having to have this use of
middleware and passing the type and
everything and to do that we need to do
some very very minor changes so we need
to add one more class I'm going to add a
middle middle
where's extensions extensions right make
a class starting and I'm gonna add a
extension method here all the use name
wrapping so this thing here it's gonna
be extension method is going to be named
use name rightly and it's going to take
an i application builder and it's gonna
do the cool to use middleware for me
main thing here is a lot of people who
miss out on a very neat little feature
is that don't put it in your own
namespace move it to the Microsoft or
ASP net or don't builder namespace
instead this if you move it to that
namespace which happens to be the same
namespace that the AI application
builder interface is located in it means
that whenever you come in here to your
if you if you have this in a separate
assembly or in a nougat package or
something like that since you all always
all have this using statement up here is
already going to be in there whenever
you go for F dot views it will
automatically find memra and because
it's in the namespace if you've already
got and that's the way that they do all
of these extension methods for all the
different middlewares that we're using
they just put them in the same namespace
if there is time now we've got this nice
little use name round name I go back
here we can have it look and see that it
actually still works actually might be
to have to restart patients alright we
try heading again and there it is so my
name wrapping slop and we're running and
I
saying that potentially having your
routing engine being like this is an
optimal solution and it's obviously
going to cause problems like the start
page here is still gonna have the wrong
URLs and things like that but important
thing to take away here is how easy it
is to actually plug into the request
pipeline we can do a bunch of really
cool things because being that is a
low-level API that basically gets to
look at every single incoming and
outgoing requests at a request level it
means that we can do things like rewrite
it we can make changes we can intercept
things we can modify things and
everything that we're doing in extra and
core is based on that idea there's one
little thing that they introduced these
middle words that we're building they
are actually Singleton's so whenever you
read this trip middleware it becomes a
singleton by default if you ever needed
a middleware to be non singleton you had
kind of like an issue because it wasn't
supported previously as today a fairly
late versalife to that core you can
actually go and you this is I know I
told you you didn't have to implement an
interface but for a non singleton
middleware you're gonna go in and you
can implement a an interface called I
middle where the I'm middleware it's
interesting because it makes because
this used to make some changes obviously
first of all the the reference to the
next delegate cannot be passed into the
constructor because well that would make
it impossible for you to reuse it so
what happens is that for a non singleton
middleware we actually ended up moving
our request delegates down to our
methodist register down for in focusing
now that we have we have the same
middleware but it's implementing i'm
middleware instead and we've moved the
request delegates down to to the invoke
a sink instead in the constructor and
finally the last thing we need to do is
we have to go up to our historic our
configure services and say services
Dodd's
add transient and what we want to add is
name relative middleware that and once
we've got that going that's all we need
to do so if we're going to run this now
it I'd put a breakpoint in here you can
see that actually cools the constructor
for every single request that comes in
so if I go for it again it use it up
against you you've broken away from the
problem of having to be singleton which
actually causes some problems in certain
middlewares just remember that depending
on where you put your middleware in your
requests pipeline you might have it
being you it up very very often because
in my case I'm putting it after the
static files which is probably a good
idea because if I'm just requesting a
static file like the CSS file rate and
if file or a PNG or whatever then I
probably don't need to put up my name
wrap answer is no reason for me to
initialize or create a new instance of
that middleware so remember once you go
away from Singleton's you do have a
little bit of a performance impact built
into creating a new one for every single
request and goes as far as your middle
way um okay so now you've seen mid
whereas most of you have potentially
seen that already not a big big deal I'm
going to try one more thing here so my
awesome source company asks every other
company in the world obviously has an
API as well right it has this API here a
slash API slash user slash one I go send
it's gonna make a request and I'm gonna
get hedy lamarr back fine works as it
should um but what if I go to my headers
and I tell it that hey by the way I want
this to come back as XML I know that
everybody hates XML nowadays but they're
with me just say that ok I want to have
XML and then we do so we put that in to
accept XHTML
we send that and I'm still getting Jason
back the reason that we're getting Jason
back is that in recent versions or sorry
in not that core I think it was
different if I remember it wrong in
classical MVC they actually had the XML
stuff already in place
actually not in place if you wanted to
support both Jason and XML what we need
to do is we need to go into the startup
and in this here called to add
controllers with use we had this cool
back here and in this cool back we can
go ahead and we can write options dot
output for matters both add you and this
is gonna be fine XML serialize hood for
matter what XML serialize
formatter
that's the one so by just adding that it
adds what's called a formatter
so that formatter by default is gonna
look at the or rather there's another
class that looks at what formatter to
use and that format earn output format
or selector that is being used we'll
look at the accept hundred two as the
default if I run this now you can see
that I'm getting it back in XML so I'm
supporting both JSON and XML not a big
deal we've seen that before
but what happens when you pull up an API
controller like this and you go okay so
it's returning user and you want to
return something similar but still it
needs to be a little bit different say
that you have changed the way that the
useful gig is looking because you need
in your version of it I'm gonna simulate
that by adding a a new version of user
we're just gonna have a models folder
here and in the models folder I'm gonna
add a class I'm going to call it basic
user just imagine that I need to create
a version of the API where I can return
a basic user the basic user in this case
is a smaller version of the user is just
it removes some of the information so it
just becomes a small version of that
user now now I have two versions of user
and I want to be able to support getting
that new basic user as well so I go
ahead and I add another API endpoint
here cool get basic user and it returns
a basic user so the main problem here
and this is where
not having an audience to ask you to put
up your hands is gonna be annoying but I
assumed that some of you have already
realized that this is not going to work
if I I tried running this it will
actually throw an exception because I
have the same end point here so I
wouldn't know it's actually going to
give me hey you've got duplicate actions
here I don't know which one to use I
want to get round up because I kind of
like the idea that being able to control
what I'm getting back based on my exit
editor so a very common way to do this
can be used for versioning or different
whatever you want to use it for
versioning is a very common bird thing
in it what you do is you say accept
header and then you add a specific
version of it I want to get from this
endpoint I want to get an application /v
indeed user this is a completely made-up
stream that I've just come up with but
there is like a standard where people
are saying start with applications slash
and then the indeed thought that's
indicating that I want to have a custom
type being returned it's not good be XML
it's not going to be I'm not defining
XML or JSON I'm actually asking a
request type or a resource type but the
problem here is that a strip that core
has no idea about how to handle last so
we have to build something that supports
doing that so what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna fix that I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna say add new older
infrastructure and in my infrastructure
folder I'm gonna create a new class I'm
gonna call it accept header attribute
and it's going to look like this that's
the one I want so this class here my
accept header attribute it inherits an
attribute which means that I'm allowed
to decorate in this case I'm allowed to
decorate a method with this attribute
and then I've told it that it implements
I action constraints but I action
constraint comes out of a Spirit led
Korra or a sorry a splint that 4nbc and
what it does it allow forces me to have
these two things here it requires me to
have a accept
method that returns boolean and an order
an accepted method it basically takes a
context about the current request and
that returns true or false whether or
not this action is valid for the current
incoming request in my case I'm doing
something simple I'm just saying that
hey is it
can I use this action for this request
well let's have a look at context not
information they should be context the
request the past in headers is there any
header that starts with the accept
header that I have defined if there is
then it returns true otherwise it
returns false and then order here is
just so that you can get it we get be
evaluated in different order we are not
going to use that it's just part of the
I action constraint but having that it
means I can go to my user controller and
on this get basic user I'm gonna go and
I'm gonna add an accept header okay
except under attribute it asks me what's
the accept header well I did want to use
application I should be and the user
right so just adding that is now telling
a student cor that whenever I'm making
requests here to this end point here and
I'm passing along this header it is
gonna ask for basically find these two
actions and it's gonna ask this action
here first are you okay with getting
this request and if that the header is
Venice it's gonna say yes otherwise it's
gonna say no and if it says no it's
going to use this and if it's just yes
it's gonna use this running that means
that if I send this request now you're
gonna see that I'm now getting a small
version of my I had to Lamar if I remove
that and I send a request again I get a
full version you can imagine having days
as a versioning scheme right you could
pass in an application version instead
and then get different things and
eversion not a resource type another
thing about this is that right now I'm
stuck to doing Jason another common
scenario that people wanted like using
is that you take the application being
the use of art but then you add plus and
then whatever
formatting new one so you want it as
Jason or do you want it since XML that
is another part because right now I have
an actual selector or this Hendra
attribute here that basically defines
which action to run based on the header
but to actually format it that's a
different story so to be able to support
the idea of passing in this address here
which is application v&d
plus XML I need to tell a strip at core
what that means and the way I do that
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna add a
new class and I'm gonna call it except
under output or master select or like
there is and it looks like this except
header format left so an output format
or selector is a base class for an a
student at MDC and it is literally used
for selecting the output for matter by
default a strip that for has one built
in it looks at the accept header but it
only knows about how to map your let's
see map your XML to dis ting otherwise
it uses Jason a ciggy so what I've got
is I'm building my own one of these and
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna add a
constructor to it and in the constructor
I'm gonna accept a couple of things
first of all I want to get the options
for MVC so the object passed in here is
the object that I am configuring here in
that options I can get a hold on a few
things like did define output for
matters that have been added which in my
case is going to be the XML
serialization
and the JSON one because I know that the
Jason one is ready by default and then I
get a logger factory and what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to store all of my
output for matters it's like he used us
and I'm going to go create a full back
selector so if my selector can't handle
it I'm actually gonna fall back to the
one that MVC uses internally that means
that I don't have to figure out all the
weird scenarios that days but that team
has already figured out it's basically
I'll do my thing and if it doesn't fit
into
my selector is trying to do then hey
don't do it the old-fashioned way like
we do in a static or automatically and
also I got a content type map here and
it basically just says Jason goes to
that the mime type so Jason goes to the
mime type that and the XML goes to my
type of data now that I've got my little
thing set up I'm gonna go ahead I'm
gonna implement this it's gonna look
like this
this output for matter is going to look
at the request header so it's going to
look at the context that gets tossed in
it's gonna say is there an accept header
that starts with application V and D
thoughts
if not then hey is the full back
selector afghan-led core how to format
things I don't really care it's not my
problem if the accept error starts with
that it's just gonna go and say did
somebody pass C in a form list of for
matters because you can actually get
that passed in as well and if nobody if
it wasn't passed in if they weren't for
matters passed in I'm gonna use two ones
that I got from the constructor but the
basically the ones are good and figure
up here then I'm gonna go and change the
content type for my context based on the
method that I'm going to show you in
just a second then I'm going to ask my
formatters and I'm going to find the
first four matter that can return a
response based on the request with the
new content type and I'm going to reset
the content type back to the first
accept header and then I'm gonna return
the format and the implementation here
of the and get thing alright so it just
gets onto the first one and this method
here once again looks like this half
header it tries to look at a plus sign
inside an accept header if there is one
is gonna cut off anything that's to the
right of the plus sign which is going to
be in my case Jason or XML and then it's
gonna have a look at my map here and say
if it's Jason then return application
Jason if it's XML return text XML which
basically means that what's gonna happen
here is that when I've caste an
application slash B&B dot user plus XML
is going to rewrite this to
hexed XML and then I'm gonna ask any
formatters that can handle that and then
I'm gonna set it back to whatever I had
to begin with now I have a outfits
formatter selector all I need to do is I
need to go and tell a spread that cord
use done we do that once again by using
the services I'm gonna go a services and
singleton and it's going to be an output
whose output for master cylinder on a
note on a nose and it's gonna be mapped
to accept header output format or
selector like that and I need to do that
so now by doing by doing this call here
after this call here I'm replacing the
one that I spent at uses internally and
using my own version of it instead with
that in place I can go back to insomnia
I can make my cool with BMD user XML and
it comes back is much smaller than my
small objects the VND user in version of
the resource in XML format I remove that
that paste hey as in JSON I get the same
object with Jason if I pass in nothing I
get the full object I can get the full
object in XML format and I can get the
small or big default format of Jason as
well using these little fastest it
allows us to do a bunch of really cool
things from an API point of view not
necessarily very useful for MVC for the
web but if you're building API sand
doing REST API so being able to actually
hook into the accept header and do
different mappings based on that is
actually very very powerful um okay so
now we've seen some formatting one thing
I've got that I want to show you in this
project I've got one more thing here and
that's we go into exhibition to close
that if we go into the user controller
I'm not too happy about this actually
ask user level it gets an integer passed
in in both of these and in both cases it
goes and does the same thing as
developers were always told that you
should be draw you should not repeat
yourself
so having code if I haven't had more
versions of this or whatever I would
have had to have these calls all over
the place we can get away from that
there are other reasons for doing this
but it would be kind of nice to be able
to write this instead right so much less
code if I could just go on write this
instead much cleaner much nicer I'm
gonna change it to be user I'm gonna go
and remove that which this away as well
and just return a basic user and I'm
going to remove that cool as well
probably now we said a spur that core
has no idea how to serve that request it
had it were map it to a user so I need
to tell it how to do the model binding a
very simple thing to do we're not very
simple but very simple we go and we
create a user model binder the model
binder and a user model binder it looks
like this basic model binder is a class
that implements my model binder which
requires you to have a method called
bind model async that returns the tasks
and takes a binding context in my case
I'm also really a constructor so I can
get my user ship for Satori Hostin and
the implementation here is buying model
in there first thing verified that the
context is actually being passed in
message it next here I'm doing a little
tweak and what I'm getting here from
binding context of model metadata dot
name is actually the name of the
parameter that I'm trying to bind so
this this part here is gonna say user
and then I'm gonna because that's what
what they're called here then I'm going
to take the user I'm going to append ID
automatically to it so I'm just gonna
say that if the parameter in is called
user I'm gonna turn the key into user ID
then I'm gonna ask the binding context
can you please give me a see if somebody
is passed in a user ID parameter as a
host argument or it's a query parameter
or whatever
if I don't get a user ID pass back then
I'm gonna return nothing otherwise I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm gonna take the
value that I get back verify that it's
it's not null or empty and I'm gonna
take that value I'm gonna try to parse
it so I'm going to say take the user ID
that somebody posted to me or added in
the curse ring or added as a parameter
in a in the URL and try to parse that as
an integer if that doesn't work add a
model error and then basically just
return and say nope didn't work and
solve it otherwise if it could pass it
parse it as an integer go and ask the
users for that user ID find the user and
then tell the binding context that hey I
was successful to do the binding for you
here is 200 because you should use I
take that and I go to my startup
actually we need one more things sorry
this is just a binder
we need something called and model bind
your provider as well and it creates a
user mojo binder provider this remote
abundant writer so the most binder
provider is like a company of a friend
class - the model binder in the way that
it takes a model binder contact multiply
the provider context that says hey can
you please give me a model binder we can
register a bunch of these model binder
providers and all this thing in us it
looks at the model date model
information it says hey are you trying
to bind a user in that case I think you
should use this model binder here and
know I'm not actually giving it my model
binder I'm giving it a binder type model
binder and passing it in the type of my
model binder it is because this finder
type model binder it does dependency
injection for me and since I am doing
dependency injection in my user model
binder you use this extra thing around
it to support a dependency injection now
that I have a model binder and a model
binder provider
all I have to do is go to the services
register my model binder not there but
in ear I say options thought model
binder providers and here's a little
quickie
you have to do insert 0 or whatever but
if you don't insert at the top it
actually goes in order and it's going to
make sure that the first one that it
finds that that returns a modal binder
is the one that it uses and that is
unfortunately if I if you're doing add
mine is gonna end up at the end a nice
but mentor is always gonna have one that
says I know how to do it so we want to
have this thing at the beginning I'll
take this and we put a breakpoint here
is s five going to debugging doesn't
really matter because I'm not doing that
you go to insomnia and I ascend here and
I set my breakpoint in the right one
that one send you can now see that it's
actually bounded straight to my update I
don't have to get the idea
and do the ID to what we converse from
my own I can actually have it bound to a
real object straight away there are some
downsides to it it makes it harder for
you to figure out if stuff is failed and
you cannot add your own error messages
and things like that so you need to get
around that and also it's not really
recommended to run off the database for
example which is kind of what I'm doing
because it might be slow and that should
potentially be done with inside of your
action so you can handle error states
and things like that but it shows you
that model binders can be a really
powerful way of doing things as well
okay so I'm gonna step away from my
awesome source company and I'm gonna
show you another company here which is
my enterprise employee management system
if we start that up and look like this
this is my enterprise employee
Management Inc I'm going to log in as
Grace and if we go to here we can see
that race can manage users and one of
the things you can do is you can add new
users if you can go and add another user
here it's gonna be Jane Doe with a CEO
and that's that's also works
fine and it's got security I have to
login and if we look at the the
controller here for my employees
controller it uses authorize so it
should be all safe rights shouldn't be
any problems with with any product thing
here I can get to this without being
your bin then unfortunately our dear
friend grace process to our evil hacks
recites evil exercise side she she
refreshes that and that's not gonna work
I mean I was supposed to work nicely for
you I'm gonna start my evil hexer sites
and it looks something nothing really
happens and like we can refresh that a
couple of times nothing really happens
and then Ray's come back to her her work
site again and all of a sudden why is
this not working now a distorted project
there's something with my machine today
that it's not working properly I don't
know why all right
this was supposed to do a really sweet
thing and it does it does cool bad ah I
know let's just try and look out I'm
just gonna look back in again it just
works now all right oh come on do this
I'm gonna take my evil hexer sighs I'm
not here Russ that once again refresh a
couple of times go back to this thing
here and are there now it's working
don't know oh yeah I know why it has to
do with the way that my browser's are
set up to different accounts anyhow what
happens here is that all of a sudden
might have evil haxor all over the place
and what is really happening is in this
site here I'm doing some cross-site
request forgery if we look at the
network when I load this it actually
loads and hacks are formed with HTML
that does opposed to the employees ad
endpoint and due to the fact that I'm
already logged in here
I am authenticated because the browser
is nice enough to add the cookie for me
and I logged in this
only wear does not work in Chrome by the
way because Chrome has fixed their
cookie handling so it would actually
lock it for you but for all other
browsers this is still a problem I can
still go and do very simple requests and
request forgeries and get stuff being
put in like this but when they start
that core you really should never have
that problem because if we go to the
forum and if we do an inspect here and
we assume you can see here that inside
of my forum there's actually a request
verification token being added whenever
you add a forum in asp.net poor you
actually get requests request forgery
checks built-in so basically whenever
you use a form in my case view looks
like this whenever you use a form like
this a spit net cor automatically adds
that request forgery check for us the
only thing we need to do is we need to
go in to our code go to the add method
and Saif Ali Bey and before jury token
like that not a very big deal to do but
once you've got that going if we refresh
this site now let's go back to the home
page it's gonna have lost everything
because it's just an in-memory database
but if I go to evil hacks recycle i
refresh this now you can see that it
goes and gives red it goes 400 and the
reason for that is that the evil hexer
site doesn't have the actual request
forgery stuff that's needed to do it but
if I go in here and I go and create a
new user it's still going to work fine
because it validates everything that's
needed I wouldn't really recommend doing
validate and before jura tokens like
this what you want to do instead is that
whenever you start an ace application
you want to go into your your eggs but
net configuration you're in add
controllers you want to go and say
options and all you need to do is save
options got filters got ad which adds a
global filter that is for every single
request and then you add an auto
validate empty forger token attribute
once you've got that it will actually
add an to forgery checks for every risky
HTP verb that you've got so every time
you're passing in a post or a patch or a
PUD or a delayed it will actually verify
that you have a value and to forgery
tokens in place otherwise it won't work
and all you need is that one line of
code and you're good to go and it works
with single page applications the last
thing I want to show in this product
here is that as you can see we can add
profile pictures problem with profile
picture sees that we'd never know how
big they are right so we need to have a
way to create thumbnails thumbnails is a
resource intensive thing to do and it
would be kind of nice if we could do
those in the background so that
interrupts our actual application so I'm
gonna go and I'm going to create a
background put process for that so I'm
going to add a new folder called
infrastructure and in my infrastructure
folder i'm gonna create what I call a
thumbnail generator nope yeah in there
ready sir yes and the implementation is
actually not that complicated it is
what's called an I hosted service an i
hosted service is a class that supports
and start async and stop async and it's
gonna run in the background inside of
your a script that process another thing
I need here is I need to have a nail um
they'll generate your constructor
because I need a few things I need the
hosting environment that I'm working I
need my employees I need to have a
filesystemwatcher to get everything
working once I've got those things in
the store async I'm gonna go ahead and
do this I'm going to make sure that
there's a folder in the dub-dub-dub root
folder called images slash in place and
then I'm going to add a
filesystemwatcher that listens to these
files being created inside that folder
whenever a file is being created I'm
gonna call a method pool
I'll create it that looks like this it
actually I'm not going to cover the font
file of such for this method very much
but what it does it looks at the file
name it finds out the tenant name and
employee ID from the naming of the file
and then it basically uses yep right I
need a nougat package here image shirt
image short nothing there
it uses image short to basically create
a thumbnail and there is so it's
basically just create a thumbnail for me
but it runs in the background which is
kind of cool and then for the stop I'm
gonna have AIDS of basic and all that
does is basically unhooks then lab
handler its disables racing events this
disposes to filesystemwatcher once I
have one of these I hosted services I
can go to my services collection and I
can say services God add a hosted
service I'm going to add a nail and
array one of those like that so now I
have this thumbnail generator thing
right and ice or my application I say
I'm gonna put a breakpoint in I'll
created here I go f5 so I'm attaching a
debugger and here we can see I'm gonna
do add profile picture I'm gonna upload
a profile picture and some from image
here upload because he jumps straight in
here which is cool I can go f5 and it
comes back again and this time it is the
thumbnail that's going because it says
for the first image being created is 1-1
that's John that though and then it
creates a thumbnail and due to the fact
I'm creating a thumbnail it gets cold
again because it's looking for every
single file being created
but you can see that I'm actually in
here blocking my thread right now and if
I go back out here I've already put my
response back so the actual code image
generation is being done in the
background threads if I let this run
through if i refresh this page here my
thumbnail comes up in the background
when I'm done with it so if you have
like slow long running tasks you can
have them in a background thread using a
home to service in a very simple way
which solves a bunch of really cool and
interesting problems okay that was kind
of the intro to think you can do next
but at the core it's not complicated a
lot of people have already seen it the
next one is a bit more complicated so I
looked at at Asher and Web Apps and if
you go into Windows Azure and your
Mike's of Thatcher and you go into Web
Apps there's a little tick box that you
can say add an application insights and
magically application insights is not
part of your application I was sort of
thinking how did they actually do that
how did they extend my application with
application insights code without me
adding any code into my application and
that is kind of what I want to show you
you can actually extend applications
with code without having to modify your
own code which means that when you're
deploying to not only ask about your own
servers you can make sure that every web
application deployed to your server will
automatically incorporate a bunch of
features that you have defined
application insights is just one of
those common scenarios that a lot of
people know that a little tick box and
magically it has functionality you can
do the same so what I've got is I've got
something I called request Diagnostics
really stupid example it's got a
Diagnostics log class all it really does
is that it has a laundry method that
takes a string it stores the strings in
a dictionary or sorry a list and then it
uses a application lifetime to figure
out when application is stopping and
whenever the application is stopping
then I tell the file says the file here
to write my logs to
physical file and whenever the
application starts out it reads the log
messages in again it's basically just a
stupid in memory list of blog entries
that gets persisted between application
starts to not implement this
introduction in any way it's it's dumb
and it poses problems and it's a massive
memory leak in every single way but I
just want to show you an example of
something so this Diagnostics log is one
part of my system the other part is a
Diagnostics middleware this middleware
plugs in and gives you a request
endpoint called slash Diagnostics and if
you go to slash Diagnostics and you are
in development and the in development
environment it is going to output all
the de la get this to you on the screen
as a text file that's it these are the
two things I want to plug in to my
application oh yeah I'm sorry it also it
does a logins in here so it logs
everything for it for every request if
it somewhere any up this is kind of cool
yes you use us to my ignorance this this
is what I want to extend an application
with so I want to have this login
interface and I want to have my my
endpoint here my middleware and how do I
actually extend my application without
actually going into my application and
adding a reference to this class here
that was kind of a big problem that I
was facing and the first thing I figured
out is that you can create something
called a start I'm going to add a new
class and I'm going to call it you know
Stig's
or filter if I could spell Diagnostics
diagnostic start filter do this it's
gonna look like this now most historic
filter so and diagnostic start filter is
just a class implements I start a filter
that's it I start a filter as one method
called configure and if you look at what
get passed there is an eye application
builder so this is a
you can register in di that gets to play
along in your startup class here
so whenever if you have an AI
application startup bursaries and I
start a filter in your applications
dependency I see container whenever you
get to this figure part here it is gonna
call configure on this sort of filter
allowing me to register middlewares in
my request pipeline that's part number
one of this and it also just absolutely
console.writeline so I can see that it's
actually being plugged it that I sort of
filtered allows me to plug into the
request pipeline then there's another
one that I'm gonna come out and I want
to hear called Diagnostics booth
staining startup Diagnostics so a
hosting startup isn't it's a class that
implements are hosting startup it in
turn has a configure method as well but
it takes a web host builder and this
part this application if you have one of
these it gets to play along with this
part of your application which is the
startup of your application so in your
program say yes so whenever you build
your web host we can plug into that and
what I'm doing in this is that when when
I set up my web host I go and I read
this or two services in my application
so I add my Diagnostics log and I add my
startup filter once that gets added to
my ioc container when it gets to the
configure method of the startup he's
gonna go and it's gonna run my store a
filter and distort a filter is going to
plug itself into request pot last thing
i need to do is i need to make sure that
the assembly that contains my hosting
startup needs to have an assembly
attribute called hosting Stora that
points at the class that implements i
hosting storing these really too
personal I need now that I have that I
want
start extending application with this
because now I have all the building
parts and the way I want to do this I
want to use something called a runtime
store so dotnet core or a static or I
think it's not the core in general
implement something called a runtime
store which basically allows you to take
a bunch of DLL and put them on a loop in
a location on a hard drive and then
point to that location and download
dll's from there it's kind of like a
global assembly cached without all the
downside on the global assembly cache
but it lives allows you to on a server
for example prepare that server with a
bunch of Serta DLLs that your
application needs to have and then it
can be stored on the server so that it
can be loaded by your application
without your application having to bring
everything a lot so what I've done is I
created this project here called run
time store and the only reason I have a
project here is because I I need to get
a CS Raja
let me see is part file all it does it
it changes the where it finds new get
packages it takes all the ones are
available adds new gifts and then adds a
folder installed on projects and then it
has a reference to request Diagnostics
that's my project the first thing I need
to do is I need to generate Marcus
Diagnostics nougat package and I'm gonna
do that by pulling up a PowerShell
window and I'm gonna go around and run
dotnet hatch like that I'm just packing
my request Diagnostics project into a
nougat package and what happens now if
they put the nougat package inside the
deployment packages request Diagnostics
nougats so that this requests this
package reference references that nougat
package in that folder next part I need
to do is I need to create what is called
the runtime store and what you do with
the runtime stories you have to see the
profile then you go out you run dotnet
store you give it a manifest which is
just see it's pod file with the package
reference inside let's you tell it what
runtime is going to be running on I'm
running on a Windows 10 machine it
where to put the store and in this case
I'm skipping optimization arunda what's
gonna happen now is it's gonna gather up
all of the assembly is needed to be able
to run this project here which happens
to be it needs that nougat package but
that nougat package in turn has
dependencies the other thing and it's
gonna generate a folder here or folder
structure that basically contains all of
the assemblies needed you can see all
the DL EPS in here you'll be able to run
the request by agnostic package all of
those assemblies are now loaded up if
then to this folder here called store in
a very specific format with the x64 and
not net for up 3.1 and so on and so on
now I'm a store last part I need is I
need something called index additional
depths so whenever we build an
application so I'm going to go and I'm
going to go and say both net publish I'm
gonna publish my runtime store
application this we publish it to a
temporary folder because I don't
actually need that project all I need is
when you build an extranet application
or in.net application you get this file
here called depth stop Jason it contains
all of the dependencies that should get
loaded together with your application
but what that thing there but I don't
want it to have a reference to the
actual product itself I'm good in two
places here I'm just gonna reference to
itself and just keep all of the other
references all of the other things that
is needed now I have that runtime stored
this JSON file just gonna go and I'm
gonna copy that I'm gonna do a copy from
Employment and runtime storage depth
Jason and I'm gonna copy that to
deployments additional depths shared
blah blah blah blah blah which if we go
in here and have a look it's a very
specific you air path so the additional
depths that's my folder but the shared
in Mac Microsoft a spinet core app is
basically the shared library that my
application will be based on and then
the version of the shared library that
I'm using assured framework and then my
request Diagnostics for depth 2j
which is telling it that if you ever won
a load if you have an application built
on that sharri framework that needs to
load requests Diagnostics then please go
ahead and load all of these other
dependencies as well this is a bit hard
to get your head around maybe I mean
just explaining it took me a while to
read up on and figure out but what I've
got now is I've got everything I need to
dynamically load things what I need to
do last step is I need to set up some
environment variables and if I open up
my web application the one that I want
to extend and I go into the properties
folder and the launch settings and go
into this thing here I'm going
environment variables first of all I'm
adding this additional depth so dotnet
additional depths is telling Matt that
whenever you start this application or
an application that has this environment
variable please have a look inside of
this folder for additional dependencies
who's going to look in here and it's
gonna figure out that the application
downloading is based on this shared
framework here so it's going to look
into this folder here is gonna say ooh
there is additional dependency is saying
that if you are loading request
Diagnostics please go and load these
dependencies as well then I'm gonna set
up a dotnet shared store which is
another environment variable that points
towards my store that's telling me a bit
of nerves or dognapped that if you're
looking for assemblies please look not
only in the local folder for the
application but please go ahead and look
into these assemblies as well there
might be other assemblies here that's
not in the local folder please load them
from this location instead so it's
basically pointing to the same place and
then finally you have this 8th phonetic
or hosting start up assemblies telling a
stir up that core that whenever this
application and application loads it
should load this an assembly called
request Diagnostics it has some start
close distorted stuff for me so what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna start an
application asp.net core is gonna see
that it's gonna say hey I want to know
it requests Diagnostics request
Diagnostics is not part of my
ah it's gonna go and look in the shared
store and it's gonna find the shared
store I'm gonna say hey I can see
request Diagnostics in here I'm going to
load that file the problem is that when
it tries to load request Diagnostics
from the store it's not going to have
all of the dependencies needed to run it
because they they are not in they're not
bundled together so to say there are
external dependencies so then it's going
to say hey I can also see in additional
dependencies that you are trying to load
this the year it requires me to also
load all of these other assemblies work
so in the end this with all of my talk
in all of my code and all of the
environment variables and things means
that if I run this as a console out mom
will stop this thing here I get this
console here and here is the magical
part and you see I don't know if you can
see this but it says adding generic
Diagnostics to system Diagnostics
available at Diagnostics if I go to
slash Diagnostics you can see that is
actually taking care of every incoming
request adding it to my Diagnostics and
if I go ahead and I stop my application
you will now see that you will now see
that in a second I didn't actually write
it should right up my log as well I
don't know why it is probably because I
sorry I killed it in the wrong way let's
see if I just run just one more time if
I can get the logs to actually good I
cancelled that instead instead of
killing it you get the logs here so it
did write out the logs for me as well so
this way any application in my system on
on my local machine that has these
environment variables set up which is
you set them on the environment not in
your launch things normally it means
that they get loaded in then I can
extend every single web app in my
application by just lo putting them on
my local machine I think I'm pretty
close to what the time I was allotted to
actually talk to you guys I know that
there was a lot of code and a lot of
things to have a look at so I put all of
the code on github it does include a
bunch of information so if you go to to
the address which is if I can go in
there we have a look at that there is
you
oh you're not just stuck with me
explaining it and you can try a bunch of
different things with the code I've had
I don't know I just want to thank you
all for listening I hope you got
something out of it and that you have
something that you can play around with
after the conference thank you so much